So LuAnne Johnson was a teacher, and she wrote a book about her job, and she sold that book to Hollywood. And before long, her book was made into a movie called Dangerous Minds. Now it's also a TV show, also called Dangerous Minds. And now, every week, LuAnne Johnson can turn on the TV and see a teacher with her same name march around and do things she thinks are unethical, inadvisable, and sometimes just plain silly, like holding a school fundraiser in a strip club.
卢安·约翰逊曾是一名教师，她写了一本关于她工作经历的书，并将其卖给了好莱坞。没过多久，她的书就被改编成了一部名为《危险游戏》的电影。现在，同名的电视剧也播出了。如今，卢安·约翰逊每周都能打开电视，看到一个与她同名的老师在电视里走来走去，做着她认为不道德、不明智，有时甚至非常荒谬的事情，比如在脱衣舞俱乐部举办学校筹款活动。
Number one, there's no teacher I know who would do such a thing. It's illegal. I think you'd lose your job, and I would hope you would lose your job. But I just objected to that. And I would never do it.
第一，我认识的老师里没有人会做这种事。这是非法的。我想你会丢掉工作，我也希望你会丢掉工作。但我只是对此表示反对。我永远不会这么做。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, deals with the devil. As we do every week, we've invited a variety of writers and performers onto the show with their stories. This week, all stories about selling your soul, making Faustian bargains. In our program today, Act One, Dangerous Minds. Act Two-- Act Two is actually a found tape of Satan's own telemarketer. Act Three, Voyager. Act Four, Carmen Becomes Faust. Act Five, First Contact. Stay with us.
欢迎收听来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是与魔鬼做交易。和每周一样，我们邀请了各种作家和表演者来分享他们的故事。本周的所有故事都与出卖灵魂、进行浮士德式的交易有关。今天的节目内容包括：第一幕，《危险游戏》。第二幕——第二幕其实是一段撒旦专属电话推销员的录音。第三幕，《航海家》。第四幕，《卡门变身浮士德》。第五幕，《第一次接触》。请继续收听。
Act One, Dangerous Minds. First, a word about LuAnne Johnson's book, the one that they adapted very freely into the movie and the TV show Dangerous Minds. It was called My Posse Don't Do Homework. LuAnne Johnson taught in the public schools, and she says that contrary to what you may see on the evening news, it was not a war zone.
第一幕，《危险游戏》。首先，聊聊卢安·约翰逊的书，那本被改编成电影和电视剧《危险游戏》的原著。书名叫做《我的学生不做作业》。卢安·约翰逊曾在公立学校任教，她说，与你在晚间新闻中看到的相反，学校并非战区。
No, that's one of the reasons I wrote that book, is I felt like people were just writing off kids. You know, 13, 14 years old, saying, well, they're hopeless, they're useless, and there's nothing we can do. All the things I was reading were about how horrible they are, and they have no respect for people, and they don't care, and they're unteachable. And I just don't feel that's true. I think that's really wrong.
不，这就是我写那本书的原因之一，我觉得人们只是在否定这些孩子。你知道，那些13、14岁的孩子，人们说，嗯，他们没救了，他们没用了，我们什么也做不了。我读到的所有东西都是关于他们有多可怕，他们不尊重人，他们不在乎，他们无法教导。我只是觉得那不是真的。我认为那大错特错。
Well, LuAnne Johnson's deal with the devil proceeded in several stages. First the film, which starred Michelle Pfeiffer, came out, I don't know, two years ago I think, three years ago. And LuAnne Johnson did like some things about the film.
嗯，卢安·约翰逊与魔鬼的交易经历了几个阶段。首先是电影，由米歇尔·菲佛主演，我不记得了，大概是两三年前上映的吧。卢安·约翰逊确实喜欢电影中的某些东西。
The primary lesson I always try to teach my students is you choose who you are. You can throw up your hands and blame everyone in the world and say, I can't earn an A, I can't do this, I have to do that. You don't have to do anything. You don't have to come to school. You choose to be here. Now you can choose to learn, or you can choose to vegetate. I think that came across in the movie, that there is hope, that you're not a victim.
我一直试图教给学生的首要课程是，你选择成为什么样的人。你可以摊开双手抱怨全世界，说我拿不到A，我做不到这个，我必须做那个。你其实什么都不必做。你不必来学校。是你选择来这里的。现在你可以选择学习，也可以选择虚度光阴。我认为电影里传达出了这一点，即希望是存在的，你不是受害者。
Man, you don't understand nothing. I mean, you don't come from where we live. You're not bussed here.
伙计，你根本什么都不懂。我是说，你不是来自我们住的地方。你不是坐校车来的。
Do you have a choice to get on that bus?
你有选择不坐那辆车的权利吗？
Man, you come and live in my neighborhood for one week, and then you tell me if you've got a choice.
伙计，你来我们社区住上一周，然后再告诉我你有没有选择。
There are a lot of people who live in your neighborhood who choose not to get on that bus. The people who choose to get on that bus, which are you, are the people who are saying I will not carry myself down to die. When I go to my grave, my head will be high. That is a choice. There are no victims in this classroom.
在你那个社区里，有很多人选择不坐那辆校车。而选择坐校车的人，也就是你们，是在说我不会自甘堕落。当我走进坟墓时，我会昂首挺胸。那是一种选择。在这个教室里没有受害者。
But the movie took some liberties with LuAnne Johnson's book. For instance, the filmmakers made her mixed race class into an all minority class. The filmmakers invented fictional black parents who did not want their kids to learn. The filmmakers organized the film around two stories which did not happen in real life. In one, LuAnne Johnson gets so overwhelmed by how impossible it is to make progress with her kids that after just a few months, she decides to quit. And in the other, a student is shot and killed. And she feels that these things reinforce the very stereotypes that she was trying to dispel by writing her book in the first place.
但电影对卢安·约翰逊的书进行了一些艺术加工。例如，电影制作人把她班上的混合种族学生改成了全少数族裔班级。制作人虚构了一些不想让孩子学习的黑人父母。制作人围绕两个现实中并未发生的故事来组织电影。在一个故事里，卢安·约翰逊对教育这些孩子的无力感感到崩溃，仅仅几个月后就决定辞职。在另一个故事里，一名学生被枪杀。她认为这些内容强化了她写书初衷正是为了消除的刻板印象。
And I think the movie really promotes racial tension by constantly pitting black against white, having the kids call me "white bread," which never happened. It just, it didn't happen.
我认为这部电影通过不断挑起黑人与白人的对立来煽动种族紧张关系，让孩子们叫我“白面包”，这从未发生过。它就是，它没有发生过。
And I said to them, why'd they do that? And they said, well, we found it hard to believe that a classroom of black and Hispanic kids would welcome a white teacher and give her any respect. And I said, but it's not a matter of your skin color, it's a matter of how you treat them. But they couldn't believe that. And they still don't. And I think there are a lot of people who do believe that you can't walk into a classroom filled with minority kids and they're going to treat you right.
我对他们说，你们为什么要那样做？他们说，嗯，我们觉得很难相信一个由黑人和西班牙裔孩子组成的班级会欢迎一位白人老师并给予她任何尊重。我说，但这与你们的肤色无关，这取决于你们如何对待他们。但他们无法相信。他们现在仍然不相信。我认为有很多人确实认为，你不可能走进一个满是少数族裔孩子的教室，而他们会善待你。
Around this time, her deal with, well, with Hollywood, let's just say, with Hollywood took other turns. A new printing of the book My Posse Don't Do Homework came out.
就在这个时候，她与，嗯，与好莱坞的交易，我们就说与好莱坞的交易吧，发生了其他转折。《我的学生不做作业》出了新版。
And when I got that in the mail, I opened it up. And it said Dangerous Minds.
当我收到邮件打开它时，上面写着《危险游戏》。
As the title it said Dangerous Minds?
书名写的是《危险游戏》？
Yeah. It said Dangerous Minds, and it had the movie poster on it. And it said by LuAnne Johnson. And I thought, well, I didn't write a book called Dangerous Minds. How can they do this? So I called my editor, and I said, "How can you do this? How can you change the title of my book without even telling me?" And she said, "It's not your book. It's our book. You wrote it. We bought it. We own it."
是的。上面写着《危险游戏》，还有电影海报。作者写的是卢安·约翰逊。我心想，嗯，我没写过一本叫《危险游戏》的书。他们怎么能这么做？所以我给编辑打了电话，我说：“你们怎么能这样？你们怎么能在不告诉我的情况下更改我的书名？”她说：“这不是你的书。这是我们的书。你写的。我们买了。它是我们的。”
Not long after that, executives, executives somewhere in America, decided to exercise a clause in an old contract that she had signed, and her deal took this turn.
没过多久，美国某处的执行官们决定行使她签署的一份旧合同中的条款，她的交易就这样发生了转变。
Someone called me and said, did you hear? I heard they're making a TV show out of your book. And I said, oh  really? Oh, that's interesting. So I called my agent in Los Angeles and said, "They're making a TV series? I would like to consult, because I don't want them to do what they did with the movie, get so far removed from reality. I'd really like to have something to do this time."
有人给我打电话问，你听说了吗？我听说他们要把你的书拍成电视剧。我说，哦真的吗？哦，那真有趣。所以我给在洛杉矶的经纪人打电话说：“他们要拍电视剧？我想参与咨询，因为我不希望他们像对待电影那样，离现实太远。这次我真的想做点什么。”
So she called back later and said, "No, they said they don't need you. They don't want you. They can't afford you." And I said, "What do you mean? I know I'm a lot cheaper than those Hollywood people." So, call them back.
后来她回电说：“不，他们说他们不需要你。他们不想要你。他们雇不起你。”我说：“你什么意思？我知道我比那些好莱坞的人便宜得多。”所以，回电给他们。
That's right. Apparently they haven't heard about educational salaries in America.
没错。显然他们还没听说过美国的教育工资水平。
Right. And then there was some discussion between her and them and me. And in fact, I asked one of the producers how much they're paying the writers. I said, "I heard you were paying them $50,000 each per episode." And he said, "Oh no, we're only paying them $30,000 plus perks."
对。然后她和他们以及我之间进行了一些讨论。事实上，我问过其中一位制片人他们给编剧付多少钱。我说：“我听说你们每集给他们付5万美元。”他说：“哦不，我们只付给他们3万美元外加福利。”
Per episode?
每集？
A week. And we asked them to pay $25,000 for a year. And they said, "Well, we'll see. Probably not."
每周。而我们要求他们每年支付2.5万美元。他们说：“嗯，我们看看。大概不行。”
Again, there are things about the TV series that LuAnne Johnson likes. She likes, especially, the feisty, in-your-face way that Annie Potts plays her, for example. But she also finds plenty that makes her uncomfortable. Like that episode where the students stage the fundraiser in the strip club. They hold something called a hair war.
同样，电视剧里也有一些卢安·约翰逊喜欢的地方。例如，她特别喜欢安妮·波茨饰演她时那种活泼、直率的方式。但她也发现了许多让她不舒服的地方。比如那集学生在脱衣舞俱乐部举办筹款活动。他们举办了一场所谓的“发型战争”。
What? What is a hair war?
什么？什么是发型战争？
It's kind of like a fashion show, only with hairdos.
有点像时装秀，只不过主角是发型。
You're trying to tell me that people will come and lay down good money to watch us get our hair curled?
你是想告诉我人们会花大价钱来看我们卷头发吗？
Where've you been, in a coma? This ain't your everyday, walk-around hair.
你去哪了，在昏迷吗？这可不是你们平时随便弄的那种头发。
So I called the producer, Andy Schneider, and I said, "Andy, I'm very upset about this." He said, "Well, what's your problem?" And I said, "Where do I start? Would you like if your 14-year-old or 15-year-old daughter came home from school and you found out her teacher had taken her to a strip club?" And he didn't answer that.
所以我打电话给制片人安迪·施奈德，我说：“安迪，我对这件事非常不满。”他说：“嗯，你有什么问题？”我说：“我从哪儿开始说起呢？如果你的14岁或15岁女儿放学回家，你发现她的老师带她去了脱衣舞俱乐部，你会高兴吗？”他没有回答。
LuAnne Johnson, the real one, not the TV one, is trying to raise millions of dollars to start a new school these days. And having herself portrayed on national television this way every week, she feels, is not going to help her credibility.
真正的卢安·约翰逊，不是电视里的那个，这些天正努力筹集数百万美元创办一所新学校。她觉得，每周在全国电视上以这种方式被描述，对她的声誉没有任何帮助。
They did the hair war to raise funds because Ms. Johnson had a fight with a school board member who it turns out is taking money away from the program. For a teacher to involve kids in a political fight like that among the adults is inappropriate. It's just not professional behavior. And I wouldn't do such a thing. It's undignified, and it's silly. And he said, "Well, I think it's cute." And I said, "Well, I'll tell you what, I'm not cute, and my students don't think I am."
他们举办发型战争是为了筹集资金，因为约翰逊老师和一个学校董事会成员吵了一架，结果发现那个人正在从项目中挪用资金。对于老师来说，让孩子卷入这种成年人之间的政治斗争是不合适的。这根本不是职业行为。我也不会做这种事。这有失尊严，而且很傻。他说：“嗯，我觉得这很可爱。”我说：“好吧，我告诉你，我一点也不可爱，我的学生也觉得我不可爱。”
Modelled by Academy Program's English teacher, LuAnne Johnson.
由学院项目的英语老师卢安·约翰逊模特演示。
The last scene of the hair war episode has LuAnne Johnson on stage in a strip club modelling a big outrageous hairdo as her students cheer. If LuAnne Johnson made a deal with the devil, it was a devil whose intentions, anyway, seemed particularly benign and well meaning.
发型战争那一集的最后一幕是卢安·约翰逊在脱衣舞俱乐部的舞台上，顶着一个夸张的大发型，学生们在一旁欢呼。如果卢安·约翰逊与魔鬼做了交易，那这个魔鬼的意图看起来倒还算良善且好心。
The producers of Dangerous Minds are Andy Schneider and Diane Frolov. Before this project, they produced the offbeat program Northern Exposure for five years. They've worked together so closely for so long that they habitually finish each other's sentences. And if you ask them what they're trying to accomplish in Dangerous Minds , the goals sound remarkably similar to the ones that LuAnne Johnson had in mind when she wrote her books.
《危险游戏》的制片人是安迪·施奈德和黛安·弗洛洛夫。在这个项目之前，他们制作了五年的另类节目《北国风云》。他们长期密切合作，习惯于接对方的话。如果你问他们试图在《危险游戏》中实现什么，其目标听起来与卢安·约翰逊写书时的初衷惊人地相似。
To give voice to a lot of kids that don't have a voice in television.
为许多在电视上没有发言权的孩子发声。
We set out, we wanted to make people feel that these kids were their own kids. That's the point of the show.
我们出发时就想，让观众觉得这些孩子就像他们自己的孩子一样。这就是节目的重点。
These kids who we think of as at-risk kids, kids that come, often, from broken homes or from poverty, that they are not just statistics or something to be feared as elements of crime, but they're just kids like everybody else. They're us. We're them.
这些被我们视为“高危”的孩子，通常来自破碎家庭或贫困环境，他们不仅仅是统计数字或被视为犯罪因素而令人恐惧，他们只是像其他人一样的孩子。他们就是我们。我们就是他们。
Though the producers do not have a lot of personal experience with these kinds of teenagers, they say they get their storylines from consultants who work with teens like this-- teachers, social workers, a youth gang services counselor. They read books. They got the idea for the hair wars show from a story about hair wars in the Wall Street Journal . And they described LuAnne Johnson's phone call to them about the episode this way.
虽然制片人并没有太多与这类青少年打交道的个人经验，但他们说故事线来源于与这类青少年一起工作的顾问——老师、社会工作者、青少年帮派服务辅导员。他们读书。他们从《华尔街日报》关于发型战争的故事中获得了灵感。他们这样描述卢安·约翰逊关于那一集打来的电话。
She felt that in the end, when she participated in the hair wars, that she looked--
她觉得，最后当她参加发型战争时，她看起来——
Silly.
傻。
--silly. And our feeling is, well, that might be the case. But in terms of creating a story, and an arc in the story, and giving a satisfying conclusion, it really helped the story to have her participate in it. And we felt as writers that that was endearing, and something that was positive and really lovable about her, that she would participate in the competition.
——傻。我们的感觉是，嗯，情况可能确实如此。但就创造故事和故事弧线，以及给出一个令人满意的结局而言，让她参与其中确实对故事有帮助。我们作为编剧觉得那是讨人喜欢的，是她身上积极且可爱的一面，因为她愿意参加这种比赛。
The real LuAnne Johnson also had problems with a scene in an early program where a black character threatens to kill the TV Ms. Johnson because she's encouraging his girlfriend to go to college.
真正的卢安·约翰逊对节目早期的一幕也有意见，在那一幕中，一名黑人角色威胁要杀了电视里的约翰逊老师，因为她在鼓励他的女朋友上大学。
And I said, this is so wrong. There are black males who aren't trying to kill people. Why do you have to constantly present them as violent? They can drop out of school even and still not be a criminal.
我说，这太不对了。并不是所有黑人男性都在试图杀人。你们为什么要不断地把他们表现为暴力分子？他们即使辍学也未必会成为罪犯。
And I really resent that, because nobody ever threatened me. You know, this is totally unrealistic to think that some black girl's boyfriend's going to come and shoot the teacher because she's trying to tell the girl to go to college.
我真的很反感这一点，因为从来没有人威胁过我。你知道，认为某个黑人女孩的男朋友会因为老师劝她上大学就去开枪射杀老师，这太不现实了。
Producers Andy Schneider and Diane Frolov say that, although LuAnne Johnson herself was never threatened, other teachers in her situation certainly have been. And while they don't recall talking to LuAnne Johnson about this particular episode of the show, they don't view the scene the same way she does.
制片人安迪·施奈德和黛安·弗洛洛夫表示，虽然卢安·约翰逊本人从未受到威胁，但处于她这种处境的其他老师肯定遇到过。虽然他们不记得和卢安·约翰逊谈过这一特定剧集，但他们对该场景的看法与她不同。
The conflict was not so much about the fact that she was going to college but that he was losing control of her.
冲突的重点不在于她要上大学，而在于他正在失去对她的控制。
And that dynamic could have happened with white people or anybody.
这种动态关系可能发生在白人或任何人身上。
Then, one of the things I said to them, and I probably offended them, but I said, "I'm not trying to offend you, but I really believe that one of the problems that the script writers are having with presenting black and Hispanic males accurately is that you don't know any who you haven't mowed your lawn or served your food. You've never been to their houses."
然后，我对他们说的一句话——可能冒犯了他们，但我说：“我不是想冒犯你们，但我真心认为，编剧在准确呈现黑人和西班牙裔男性方面遇到的问题之一，是你们除了除草或端菜的人以外，根本不认识其他人。你们从没去过他们的家。”
I don't know.
我不知道。
Are we supposed to list our friends and that sort of thing in our defense?
我们难道要列出我们的朋友作为防御吗？
And the process of writing is always a process of research. So, you know, Diane and I wrote Northern Exposure for five years. We didn't know any Alaskans. We didn't know any Native Americans. But the process of writing and getting into a world is a process of researching that and coming into contact with those people that you're trying to write about.
写作过程总是研究的过程。所以，你知道，黛安和我为《北国风云》写了五年。我们不认识任何阿拉斯加人。我们也不认识任何美洲原住民。但写作和进入一个世界的过程就是研究的过程，通过接触你试图描写的人群来实现。
We're not doing this just willy-nilly.
我们不是随心所欲地这么做。
And again, I don't think we should have demographics, but our staff is largely minority, our writing staff.
再说一遍，我不认为我们应该搞人口统计，但我们的员工，包括编剧团队，大部分都是少数族裔。
And there are also former teachers on our staff.
而且我们的员工中也有前教师。
And mentors and counselors and things like that.
还有导师、顾问之类的。
What do you think the overall message of the TV series is?
你认为这部电视剧的整体信息是什么？
Ooh, that it's a war zone.
哦，那就是这儿是个战区。
So the overall message of the TV show is, in fact, the exact opposite of the kind of thing you're trying to convey with your books?
所以这部电视剧的整体信息，实际上和你试图通过你的书传达的信息完全相反？
Yeah. Yeah. It's not a new story. It's the same old story, which isn't true and never has been.
是的。是的。这不是什么新故事。是同样的旧故事，那不是真的，也从来没有真实过。
Well, we hope that's not the message of our TV series.
嗯，我们希望那不是我们电视剧的信息。
We feel that the message of the series is hope.
我们觉得这部系列剧的信息是希望。
Yes, and that people can make a difference in the lives of other people. And that these are kids, and they're, as we've said before, they're our kids. It's very disappointing to hear that from LuAnne.
是的，人们可以改变他人的生活。正如我们之前所说，这些是孩子，他们是我们的孩子。听到卢安这么说非常令人失望。
The war zone aspect of life in school is something that we will concentrate on more, only because you need conflict, you need dramatic situations, you need stakes to be high. Otherwise, I'm not sure how you make a show. I mean, you have to deal with issues that have impact.
学校生活中的战区视角是我们会更多关注的内容，仅仅是因为你需要冲突，你需要戏剧性的情境，你需要足够高的赌注。否则，我不知道怎么制作一部剧。我的意思是，你必须处理具有影响力的议题。
In a sense, this is the Faustian bargain the producers of Dangerous Minds have made. The high school in their show has more war zone moments, more heroic attempts by teachers to save kids, more crises and near crises than any real inner city high school, because they need three stories per episode, and they have to be dramatic.
在某种意义上，这就是《危险游戏》制片人所做的浮士德交易。他们剧中的高中比起任何真正的内城高中都有更多的战区时刻，更多的教师拯救孩子的英雄壮举，更多的危机和险情，因为他们每一集需要三个故事，而且必须戏剧化。
At this point, LuAnne Johnson says that she's refusing the Faustian bargain offered her by Hollywood. She has no contract with the TV series. They send her checks. She sends them back uncashed. She says if she had it all to do over again, she wouldn't have let anybody make a film or a TV series from her books unless she'd written the screenplay herself. And she's hoping the studio that produces Dangerous Minds , it's Disney, will change the way that it depicts her.
在这一点上，卢安·约翰逊说她拒绝好莱坞向她提供的浮士德交易。她与电视剧没有任何合同。他们给她寄支票，她又把支票退回，没有兑现。她说如果一切可以重来，她绝不会允许任何人把她的书拍成电影或电视剧，除非编剧是她自己。她希望制作《危险游戏》的工作室——迪士尼——能改变对她的刻画方式。
Disney somehow seems to believe that they own LuAnne Johnson the way that they own Mickey Mouse and Dumbo and that they can take this character and make her do what they want and say anything-- you know, whatever experiences they want to have her do. I maintain I'm not a character. And I don't think you should be able to have me say things or do things that I wouldn't do and misrepresent me.
迪士尼似乎认为他们像拥有米老鼠和小飞象一样拥有卢安·约翰逊，他们可以拿这个角色做他们想做的事，说他们想说的话——你知道，无论他们想让她经历什么。我坚持认为我不是一个角色。我不认为你们应该让我说出我不会说的话，或者做出我不该做的事，从而歪曲我的形象。
Of course, as the producers of Dangerous Minds point out, Disney does own a Mickey Mouse and a Dumbo and a LuAnne Johnson. They can make this character do what they want. And given the deals everyone has made, they have to.
当然，正如《危险游戏》的制片人所指出的，迪士尼确实拥有米老鼠、小飞象和卢安·约翰逊。他们可以让这个角色做任何他们想做的事。考虑到每个人都签了合同，他们也只能这么做。
Act Two, The Undiscovered Country. Well, our program today is about deals with the devil, and this next tape seemed oddly fated to end up on the show. Over the last few months, it's been sent to This American Life, not by one, not by two, but by three different radio producers in three different parts of the country, none of them knowing that the other ones were sending it.
第二幕，未知的国度。嗯，我们今天的节目是关于与魔鬼的交易，这段录音似乎奇怪地命中注定要出现在节目中。在过去几个月里，它被寄给了《美国生活》，不是被一个人，不是两个人，而是被全美三个不同地方的三位不同的广播制作人寄来的，他们彼此都不知道对方在寄这份录音。
And none of them knew where the tape came from. As best as anybody could reconstruct-- this is quite actually a little story. As best as anybody could reconstruct, NPR commentator Andrei Codrescu was leaving a party in New Orleans, put on his coat, and discovered this tape in his pocket. The tape starts with no explanation, in mid-conversation. Here are some excerpts.
他们没有人知道这份录音来自哪里。据大家拼凑——这其实是一个小故事。据拼凑，NPR评论员安德烈·科德雷斯库在离开新奥尔良的一次派对时，穿上外套，发现口袋里有这份录音。录音没有解释，从对话中间开始。以下是节选。
She just don't know me that well.
她就是不太了解我。
She knows you very well.
她很了解你。
Uh-uh. Alice don't know me that well.
不。爱丽丝没那么了解我。
She said that your mama wants to come back from the dead.
她说你妈妈想从死里复活。
My mama's not dead.
我妈妈没死。
Well, now you lying or what? You tell me the truth now.
好吧，那你是在撒谎吗？现在你得跟我说实话。
I don't have a reason to lie to you, mister, and especially about my mama.
我没理由对你撒谎，先生，尤其是在关于我妈妈的事情上。
I know, I know. But now here's the thing, now. I deal in mysticism. I bring back dead people. Is there anybody dead that you would like to bring back?
我知道，我知道。但现在是这样，我从事神秘学。我能让人死而复生。有没有什么死人你想带回来的？
No, uh-uh.
不，不。
Anybody at all?
谁都行吗？
No. I had told [? Mr. Slips ?] just now that I had wanted to talk to him about it.
不。我刚才告诉过[？斯利普先生？]我想和他谈谈这件事。
Have you ever seen a spirit?
你见过灵魂吗？
No.
没有。
You want to?
你想见吗？
No.
不想。
What?
什么？
No.
不想。
Why?
为什么？
I just don't want to see none. I have no reason to want to see one.
我就是不想见任何灵魂。我没理由想见。
Madam, can I come over to your house tonight?
夫人，我今晚能去你家吗？
Uh-uh. No. No.
不。不。不。
I want to come over and talk to you and bring a spirit along with me.
我想去你那儿，和你谈谈，还想带个灵魂去。
Well, you leave that spirit where it at, and you stay where you at.
好吧，你把那灵魂留在它待着的地方，你自己也待在你待着的地方。
But it's not a mean spirit.
但它不是个恶灵。
I don't want no kind of spirit.
我不需要任何灵魂。
I won't charge you a cent.
我一分钱都不会收你的。
I don't want to see no spirit. I don't want to be bothered with no spirit. I don't want no spirit around me. If I see a spirit, I wouldn't be able to sleep for months.
我不想见什么灵魂。我不想被灵魂打扰。我不想身边有灵魂。如果我见到灵魂，我几个月都睡不着觉。
Do you believe in spirits?
你相信灵魂吗？
No. I believe, let me tell you, I believe--
不。我相信，让我告诉你，我相信——
I'll bring it over and show him to you tonight.
我今晚带它过来给你看看。
Uh-uh, I don't want to see him.
不，我不想见它。
I'm coming tonight.
我今晚会去。
You ain't coming to my house tonight.
你今晚别想来我家。
You don't want to see the spirit?
你不想见这个灵魂吗？
No, I don't want to see no spirit.
不，我不想见什么灵魂。
Sister, there's nothing to get frightened of.
姐妹，没什么好害怕的。
Uh-uh, I don't want to see no spirit.
不，我不想见什么灵魂。
Why?
为什么？
Because I said I don't want to see no spirit. And you see, firstly, Alice lied to you. She really did. If she told you that, she's lying.
因为我说过我不想见什么灵魂。而且你看，首先，爱丽丝对你撒了谎。她真的撒了谎。如果她那么说，她在撒谎。
Alice belongs to the occult.
爱丽丝属于神秘学团体。
What is that?
那是什么？
Alice is one of our members of the spirits.
爱丽丝是我们灵魂组织的成员之一。
Alice is a spirit?
爱丽丝是个灵魂？
She is a member of our spirit group. In other words, Alice can bring the spirits back.
她是我们的灵魂小组成员。换句话说，爱丽丝能把灵魂带回来。
What do you mean? She can bring the spirit back where?
你是什么意思？她能把灵魂带到哪儿去？
She can bring them back from the dead.
她能让他们从死里复活。
Oh, she can?
哦，真的吗？
I'll have her come over with me tonight, too.
我也让她今晚和我一起过来。
You are not coming to my house, and Alice isn't either.
你别想来我家，爱丽丝也不行。
Well, do you like Alice, or what?
好吧，你喜欢爱丽丝吗，还是怎么着？
I have nothing against Alice. She is a very, very sweet person. She is a good neighbor. It is nothing in the world. I don't believe--
我对爱丽丝没什么意见。她是一个非常、非常贴心的人。她是个好邻居。这世上没什么大不了的。我不相信——
Well, we'll be over about 7:30, 8:00. As soon as it gets dark.
好吧，我们大概7:30、8:00左右过去。天一黑我们就去。
Well, I bet you you won't come in my house.
好吧，我敢说你进不了我家门。
Well, you don't like Alice? Or what is it?
好吧，你不喜欢爱丽丝吗？还是怎么回事？
I love Alice.
我爱爱丽丝。
You don't trust us?
你不信任我们？
I don't trust the spirit.
我不信任灵魂。
Will you pray with me?
你愿意和我一起祈祷吗？
When?
什么时候？
Now.
现在。
Pray, go ahead and pray.
祈祷，去祈祷吧。
Repeat after me. Oh  lord--
跟我重复。哦，主啊——
Uh-uh.
不。
Say a prayer with me.
跟我一起祷告。
Uh-uh.
不。
I want to put a hex on you.
我想对你下咒。
Uh-uh.
不。
Oh lord-- say it with me. Is Alice over there?
哦，主啊——跟我一起说。爱丽丝在那儿吗？
Uh-uh.
不。
Tell her to come talk to me.
告诉她来跟我谈谈。
Might as well see if she's home.
最好去看看她在不在家。
No. Who's this? What is your name?
不。是谁？你叫什么名字？
Uh-uh.
不。
Give me your name and everything.
告诉我你的名字和所有信息。
Uh-uh.
不。
Tonight the spirits shall come to your house.
今晚灵魂会去你家。
Uh uh. You ain't getting my name.
不。你别想得到我的名字。
I am coming over.
我会过去的。
Well, you insist on coming over somewhere where you're not welcome.
好吧，你坚持要去一个你不受欢迎的地方。
I am welcome in your house. You just don't know I am. I bring with me the love of the spirits. They want to contact you.
在你家我很受欢迎。你只是不知道而已。我带来了灵魂的爱。他们想联系你。
No spirit wants to contact me. Uh-uh.
没有灵魂想联系我。不。
Why do you say this?
为什么这么说？
Because I'm afraid of spirits.
因为我害怕灵魂。
You are not afraid. You are not afraid. You are not afraid.
你不怕。你不怕。你不怕。
Don't repeat it a third time.
别重复第三遍。
You are not afraid. Why not?
你不怕。为什么不？
Because I asked you not.
因为我请求过你不要这么做。
Are you superstitious about three?
你对数字“三”迷信吗？
Well, kind of.
嗯，算是吧。
Three, three, three,
三，三，三，
Yap, yap, yap!
哒，哒，哒！
Three,
三，
La-la-la-la--
啦—啦—啦—啦——
Three, three. 13. Say 13. Say six.
三，三。13。说13。说6。
I can't say it.
我说不出来。
Say what?
说什么？
None of it.
什么都说不出来。
None of what?
什么的意思？
What you're saying.
你说的那些。
Oh, you mean 13?
哦，你是说13？
I guess so.
我想是吧。
Well, try and say 13.
好吧，试着说13。
I can't.
我说不出来。
Can't what?
什么说不出来？
Can't say it.
说不出那个词。
Are you afraid?
你害怕吗？
I am.
我很害怕。
You're not afraid.
你不害怕。
I am afraid.
我很害怕。
No, no you aren't.
不，不，你不怕。
Yes, I am. You don't tell me what I am.
是的，我很害怕。你别告诉我我的感觉。
Do you love Jesus?
你爱耶稣吗？
I know I love Jesus.
我知道我爱耶稣。
Well, then you're not afraid.
好吧，那你就不怕。
I know Jesus don't do crazy work like that. I know. God knows--
我知道耶稣不会做那种疯狂的事。我知道。上帝知道——
Sister, this is religious worship. We're no devil people.
姐妹，这是宗教崇拜。我们不是恶魔派。
I can't have that.
我不能接受。
I'm very religious. I'm a preacher.
我非常虔诚。我是个传道人。
Look, I can't. I'm not going to say that, because I don't know you. I don't know what--
听着，我不能。我不会说那个，因为我不认识你。我不知道——
Well, our crack This American Life investigative team did some calling around. And it turns out this tape was made by an audio artist named David Black. He was living in New Orleans at the time and would just call people up as this satanic character and mess with them.
嗯，我们《美国生活》的调查小组做了一些电话调查。结果发现这份录音是由一位名叫大卫·布莱克的音频艺术家制作的。他当时住在新奥尔良，喜欢冒充撒旦角色打电话去戏弄别人。
Hello, brother?
喂，弟兄？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Could you speak louder?
你能大声点吗？
Yeah, I'll speak a little louder.
好的，我会大声点。
Let us pray together. Are you sick?
让我们一起祈祷。你病了吗？
Yeah, I'm sick.
是的，我病了。
What seems to be the problem?
出了什么问题？
I had a stroke about four, five years ago. And I've got high blood sugar.
我四五年前中风过。还有高血糖。
God bless you. God love you.
上帝保佑你。上帝爱你。
Praise the lord.
赞美主。
Repeat after me. Oh lord--
跟我重复。哦，主啊——
Oh lord--
哦，主啊——
--take my soul--
——带走我的灵魂——
--and put me over a barrel--
——把我架在桶上——
--and pull my pants down--
——把我的裤子扒下来——
--and slap me--
——拍打我——
--with the punishing rod.
——用惩罚之杖。
Forgive me of my sins--
宽恕我的罪孽——
Louder, please.
大声点，拜托。
Forgive me for my sins--
宽恕我的罪孽——
And take me to heaven--
带我上天堂——
--on a muskrat.
——坐着麝鼠。
Love me, father.
爱我，天父。
You need to be louder, please.
你需要大声点，拜托。
Love me, father.
爱我，天父。
Love me like you do--
像爱——
--the little roach--
——小蟑螂一样爱我——
--the little roach.
——小蟑螂。
Louder, louder.
大声点，大声点。
The little roach! The little roach!
小蟑螂！小蟑螂！
Take me--
带我——
--by--
——抓着——
Louder. Take me--
大声点。带我——
Take me--
带我——
--by--
——抓着——
--the--
——那个——
--jock strap--
——护裆——
--jaw strap--
--and thrash me--
——揍我——
--but love me.
——但爱我。
Amen.
阿门。
Praise the lord.
赞美主。
Take me--
带我——
Repeat after me. [JIBBERISH]
跟我重复。[胡言乱语]
[JIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
As loud as you can, brother.
尽你最大声，弟兄。
[JIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
Amen. [JIBBERISH]
阿门。[胡言乱语]
[JIBBERISH]
[胡言乱语]
Brother, do you love me?
弟兄，你爱我吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Say I love you.
说我爱你。
I love you.
我爱你。
Loud.
大声点。
I love you.
我爱你。
Is that as loud as you can talk?
你只能说这么大声吗？
I can't talk so loud.
我不能太大声。
Put your mouth close to the receiver and holler it.
把嘴贴近接收器大喊。
I love you.
我爱你。
Five times.
五遍。
I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you.
我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。
Thank you, brother.
谢谢，弟兄。
OK.
好的。
Oh lord--
哦，主啊——
You ain't through yet?
你还没完吗？
Brother. Oh lord--
弟兄。哦，主啊——
Oh lord--
哦，主啊——
--snap the button--
——扣上扣子——
--on my underwear--
——在我的内衣上——
--on my underwear.
——在我的内衣上。
And let my armpit--
让我的腋下——
--fall upon--
——落到——
--the crawfish--
——小龙虾身上——
--on the ground.
——在地上。
On the ground. Thank you, father.
在地上。谢谢，天父。
What? What?
什么？什么？
Coming up, more deals with the devil, one hidden, one intended, one for children. That's in a minute when our program continues.
接下来，更多关于与魔鬼交易的故事，一个隐藏的，一个蓄意的，一个给孩子的。节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a theme, bring you stories on that theme.
欢迎收听《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来关于该主题的故事。
And here in Chicago, where we do the show from, we have seen a spate, a passel, a whole big group of stage productions of Faust in the last few months. Randy Newman and David Mamet did their musical version at the Goodman Theater, Doorika Theater Company actually kicked the butts of Randy Newman with their version. Somebody else did one this summer, I can't remember who. Damn Yankees came through, starring Jerry Lewis.
在芝加哥，我们制作节目的地方，过去几个月里我们看到了很多场浮士德的舞台制作。兰迪·纽曼和大卫·马梅特在古德曼剧院演了他们的音乐剧版本，杜里卡剧团的版本实际上把兰迪·纽曼比下去了。今年夏天还有别人演过，我不记得是谁了。杰瑞·刘易斯主演的《该死的洋基队》也来过这里。
It's Faust, Faust, Faust. This town is Faust crazy. So we figured we should jump on the bandwagon with Satan. That's what we're doing this hour. And today's show is deals with the devil, selling your soul.
全是浮士德。这座城市简直浮士德成狂了。所以我们想，我们应该赶上这波撒旦潮流。这就是我们这一小时要做的。今天的节目就是关于与魔鬼做交易，出卖灵魂。
We are at Act Three of our program, Voyager. In the opera Faust, when the devil appears for the first time, he says, simply, "Here I am. Why are you surprised?" See, that is the way to do it. That is the way to do that. The problem in our daily lives is that when we're offered the deal with the devil, we often do not know that that is the choice we're making. This next story is about a bargain like that. This American Life producer Alix Spiegel headed home to Baltimore to meet with a friend of hers, Jayna Park.
我们来到了节目的第三幕，《航海家》。在歌剧《浮士德》中，当魔鬼第一次出现时，他简单地说：“我在这儿。你为什么惊讶？”看，那才是正确的做法。这才是该有的样子。现实生活中的问题是，当我们被提供与魔鬼的交易时，我们往往不知道这就是我们所做的选择。下一个故事就是关于这样的交易。《美国生活》制作人阿丽克斯·斯皮格尔回到了巴尔的摩，去见她的朋友杰娜·帕克。
Jayna and I meet in the courtyard of the Peabody Conservatory of Music, then walk down the street to Louis's Bookstore Cafe. When we were teenagers, Jayna and I would go to Louis's between orchestra and violin lessons. We'd eat fish sandwiches, talk about music, and gawk at the art boys.
杰娜和我约在皮博迪音乐学院的庭院见面，然后走下街去路易斯书店咖啡馆。我们十几岁的时候，杰娜和我会在管弦乐课和钢琴课之间去路易斯咖啡馆。我们吃鱼肉三明治，谈论音乐，盯着艺术系男生看。
Jayna is Korean. When Jayna was 11, Jayna, her mother, her violin teacher, and her aunt, all drove four hours from the small town where she grew up to Seoul, South Korea's capital. They went to a big hotel, the hotel where all the Korean celebrities and international tourists stayed, and went to the room of violinist Berl Senofsky. She played him the Mendelssohn violin concerto.
杰娜是韩国人。杰娜11岁那年，她和母亲、小提琴老师以及姨妈一起，开车四个小时从她长大的小镇赶往韩国首都首尔。他们去了一家大酒店，那是韩国名人和国际游客住的酒店，然后去了小提琴家伯尔·塞诺夫斯基的房间。她为他演奏了门德尔松小提琴协奏曲。
I think the first thing he said was-- well, the first thing that my aunt translated to us was-- she should come to the States and study with me. Is that possible? Is that possible? Like, would your family allow her to go? Asking my mother this, basically. And I remember my mother just being like, what? What? What? You want what? You know, like she was just utterly confused. And then at the same time, I could see her just like sort of smiling. Like she couldn't believe her daughter, you know, whatever.
我想他说的第一件事是——嗯，我姨妈翻译给我们的第一件事是——她应该来美国跟我学习。这可能吗？这可能吗？比如，你的家人会允许她去吗？基本上是在问我母亲。我记得我母亲当时就像是，什么？什么？什么？你要什么？你知道，她完全困惑了。但同时，我能看到她脸上露出某种微笑。好像她无法相信自己的女儿，你知道，等等。
No one in Jayna's family really knew what she'd be getting into if she accepted Senofsky's offer to go to America. But it was clear from the beginning that if Jayna went, she would go alone.
如果接受塞诺夫斯基去美国的邀请，杰娜的家人没人真正知道她会陷入什么境地。但从一开始就很清楚，如果杰娜去，她将独自前往。
My dad was talking about, you know, maybe we might have to give her up for adoption. I kind of almost remember feeling like, he's asking me, like, would I be willing to give up my parents and my family for this glamorous life, or whatever? And at the time I didn't understand. I was like, how can you ask me this question? I don't want to give up anything.
我父亲谈论的是，你知道，也许我们得把她送去领养。我几乎记得当时的感觉，他像是在问我，如果你愿意为了这种光鲜亮丽的生活放弃父母和家庭吗？当时我不明白。我就想，你怎么能问我这个问题？我不想放弃任何东西。
Later, at Jayna's house, she brings out the violin. I ask her to play me the Mendelssohn, the song that she played for Mr. Senofsky, the song that literally divided her life into past and present. The opening melody is famous for being hard to play.
后来，在杰娜家，她拿出了小提琴。我请她为我演奏门德尔松，就是那首她为塞诺夫斯基先生演奏的曲子，那首把她的生活一分为二的曲子。开头的旋律因演奏难度极高而闻名。
[INAUDIBLE] [PLAYING VIOLIN]
[听不清] [演奏小提琴]
I remember the first time I saw Jayna. She was short and chubby, and dressed in a red Korean coat. Immediately after coming to America, Jayna dropped about 20 pounds. I remember people whispering that she was chubby when she arrived because meals were the only time that Jayna's strict Korean mother would allow her to stop practicing. There were other rumors, all part of the Jayna mystique, the young Korean prodigy who had sacrificed so much, come alone from Korea to study in Baltimore.
我还记得第一次见到杰娜的情景。她又矮又胖，穿着一件红色的韩国大衣。来到美国后，杰娜立刻瘦了20磅左右。我记得人们悄悄议论说她刚到时胖是因为吃饭是杰娜严厉的韩国母亲唯一允许她停止练琴的时候。还有其他传言，都是杰娜神秘色彩的一部分，那位牺牲了这么多、独自从韩国来到巴尔的摩学习的年轻韩国神童。
Classical music, like ballet or gymnastics, is a discipline with a torrentious aesthetic. The greater the sacrifice, the bigger the hero. And to Peabody, a second-rate music school in a second-rate town, Jayna's sacrifice and talent were Olympian. We were all awed. No one so young played so well.
古典音乐，就像芭蕾或体操一样，是一种有着痛苦审美的学科。牺牲越大，英雄越伟大。对于皮博迪这个二流城镇里的二流音乐学院来说，杰娜的牺牲和天赋简直是奥林匹克级别的。我们都感到敬畏。没人能像她这么小年纪就弹得这么好。
Jayna moved in with a host family, the Kilsteads. Carla Kilstead, another Senofsky student, was about the same age as Jayna and I. We would all hang out together, play Space Invaders in the Peabody lounge and beg money off our moms for the candy machines.
杰娜搬进了一个寄宿家庭，基尔斯特德一家。卡拉·基尔斯特德是另一名塞诺夫斯基的学生，和杰娜还有我差不多大。我们常在一起玩，在皮博迪休息室玩《太空入侵者》，然后向我们的妈妈讨钱去买自动贩卖机的糖果。
Then I remember you being in the car with my mom, and me, and Carla.
然后我记得你跟我妈妈、我还有卡拉在车里。
Was this like the first time ever that I came to Peabody?
这是我第一次来皮博迪吗？
This was the first time ever. And I remember we were driving past the Inner Harbor, and there was a ship.
这是第一次。我记得当时我们开车经过内港，那里有一艘船。
Ship. That was my first curse word, because, yeah, you and Carla were trying to teach me. Like, you guys just took me by the hand, OK, look, see, that's a ship. And I was like, ah, ah, [BLEEP], [BLEEP].
船。那是我的第一个脏话，因为，是的，你和卡拉当时在教我。就像，你们带我手把手教学，OK，看，看见没，那是一艘船。我就说，啊，啊，[消音]，[消音]。
Jayna says the first couple of years in America were everything she wanted them to be. Everything was new. Everything was interesting. Her life with her host family was good. She did well in competitions, and Senofsky got his manager to set up some concerts for her in Holland. Then, after two years of study at Peabody, Jayna went back to Korea for the first time. And when she came back to America, things started to fall apart. Her relationship with her host family deteriorated.
杰娜说在美国的头几年，她想要的一切都实现了。一切都是新鲜的。一切都很令人感兴趣。她和寄宿家庭的生活也很融洽。她在比赛中表现出色，塞诺夫斯基让他的经纪人为她在荷兰安排了一些音乐会。之后，在皮博迪学习两年后，杰娜第一次回到了韩国。当她回到美国时，事情开始分崩离析。她和寄宿家庭的关系恶化了。
I don't know what it was, but I think like around the third year, or something like that that I was living with them, I really started to feel like my presence there was a burden to them, you know? And that's when it started getting hard, because then I realized, oh my gosh, what am I doing? I've been here, I've been living with a family that's not mine, basically strangers. What can they possibly like about this?
我不知道是什么原因，但我觉得大概在第三年左右，我住在那儿的时候，我真的开始觉得我的存在对他们来说是一个负担，你知道吗？那时生活开始变得困难，因为我意识到，天哪，我在做什么？我一直住在一个不是我家的家庭里，基本上是陌生人家里。他们怎么可能喜欢这一点？
She left that host family and moved in with another and then left them for another. More was expected of Jayna than of any of us, and she was essentially raising herself. She was lonely and started to miss her family in Korea. At one point, she called her mom.
她离开了那个寄宿家庭，搬到了另一个，然后又离开那个去了下一个。人们对杰娜的期望比对我们任何人都高，而她实际上是在独自抚养自己。她很孤独，开始想念在韩国的家人。有一次，她给母亲打电话。
Well, I was really upset. So I called and I was crying, and I said, you know, can I just come back and just go back to school there? At least let me try that and see if that works. And I was really hoping, if not assuming, that my mother would just say, sure, come back, you know?
嗯，我当时真的很沮丧。所以我打电话去哭着说，你知道，我能回去在那边上学吗？至少让我试一下看看行不行。我当时真的希望，如果不是认定的话，我母亲会说，当然，回来吧，你知道吗？
She said, that's ridiculous. You've been there for so long now, and now you have to carry on what you've been doing. And I just remember hanging up. I don't remember exactly what I said. I just remember hanging up, feeling so desperate.
她说，这很荒唐。你在那边已经待了这么久了，现在你必须继续做你一直在做的事情。我记得我挂了电话。我不记得确切说了什么。只记得挂断电话时，感觉无比绝望。
I remember Jayna during this part of her life. I remember driving her back from orchestra rehearsal and sitting with her in my car outside her house. I was 16 and she was 14. I remember her telling me about the problems in her family back home in Korea. Her father was having financial difficulties. Her brother was having trouble getting into the right college, which in Korea determines your whole future. And her sister had had some kind of breakdown and had been put into a mental institution.
我记得杰娜生命中的那段时间。我记得送她从管弦乐排练回家，和她坐在我家外面的车里。我16岁，她14岁。我记得她告诉我韩国老家家庭出的问题。父亲经济困难。弟弟在申请合适的大学时遇到麻烦，这在韩国决定了整个未来。妹妹似乎精神崩溃，被关进了精神病院。
It was all very draining, and Jayna was having a hard time. But what I remember best was that these crises somehow forced Jayna to think about her decision to come to America in a new way. Watching her family struggle from a distance somehow brought her face to face with her own distance from them and from her culture. I remember her telling me that she felt she could never go back to Korea, that she had missed too much.
这一切非常令人心力交瘁，杰娜的日子很难过。但我记忆最深的是，这些危机迫使杰娜以一种新的方式思考她来美国的决定。从远处看着家人挣扎，使她不得不直面自己与家人、与文化的距离。我记得她告诉我，她觉得她再也回不去韩国了，她错过了太多。
I was accused constantly by my family of becoming so Americanized. But then I would look at myself here, and I would be hanging out with my friends and stuff. And then all of a sudden, I would look at myself and just feel like, gosh, but I'm not like them. I'm not one of them. So I really just kind of felt like I didn't belong anywhere. And that's when I slept a lot.
我的家人不断指责我变得太美国化了。但当我在这里审视自己时，我会和朋友一起混什么的。然后突然间，我会看着自己，觉得，天哪，但我跟他们不一样。我不是他们中的一员。所以我真的觉得我哪儿都不属于。那时我睡了很多觉。
In the world of classical music, if you don't make it as a soloist by the time you're 16 or 17, odds are you're never going to make it. At 20, it hadn't happened for Jayna. She was still practicing and competing, but it was more of a struggle.
在古典音乐界，如果你在16或17岁之前没有成为独奏家，那你可能永远也不会成功。在20岁时，杰娜还没能做到。她还在练习和比赛，但那更像是一场挣扎。
And so one day, I just decided, OK, I'm going to try something else. I want to know what it's like to not be a violinist. So I put my violin away, and for two weeks, every day for two weeks, I was just living like a non-violinist. I was going to bookstores, looking for-- I don't know. I was reading, just trying to look for what interests me. I was just like wanting-- I don't know. I was dwelling on that luxury of being able to choose for myself. But eventually, I really missed it. I really missed the music.
所以有一天，我决定，OK，我要尝试别的东西。我想知道不是小提琴家是什么感觉。所以我把小提琴收了起来，在那两周里，每天我都像个非小提琴家一样生活。我去了书店，寻找——我不知道。我在阅读，试图寻找什么让我感兴趣。我只是想要——我不知道。我沉溺于那种能为自己做选择的奢侈中。但最终，我真的想念它。我真的想念音乐。
Someone recently wrote that the tragedy of Bob Dole is not only that he sold out his principles and sold out everything he ever believed in to become president, this deficit hawk who campaigned on the kind of tax cut he used to ridicule as voodoo economics, but that after he sold out his principles and his soul, he discovered that there were no buyers.
最近有人写道，鲍勃·多尔的悲剧不仅在于他为了成为总统而出卖了自己的原则、出卖了一切他曾经相信的东西，这个曾经嘲笑税收减免是巫术经济学的赤字鹰派现在却竞选税收减免，还在于他在出卖原则和灵魂后，发现根本没有买家。
Jayna's story reminds me of that. She agrees that yes, she made a Faustian bargain. She left her family, left her country, left her home. But she never got the fame and fortune she made all those sacrifices for. And when I talked to her, I somehow expected her to be as conflicted about it as she was when we were in my car at 16. But in fact, she was fine with it. Her feelings have changed, and she's outgrown the premise of the bargain. She doesn't particularly want to be a soloist, and she's not driven for fame.
杰娜的故事让我想起这一点。她同意，是的，她做了一笔浮士德式的交易。她离开了家人，离开了国家，离开了家园。但她并没有得到她为之做出所有牺牲的名利。当我跟她交谈时，我本以为她会像我们16岁坐在车里时那样纠结。但实际上，她对此感到还好。她的感受改变了，她已经超脱了交易的初衷。她并不是特别想成为独奏家，她也不追求名声。
With or without violin, Jayna clearly prefers life in America to the restricted life she would have had in Korea. And though recently her parents have started talking about coming to the States, moving in with her so that they can be closer, she finds these conversations make her nervous. She doesn't want to give up the independence she's had since she was 11.
无论有没有小提琴，杰娜显然更喜欢在美国的生活，而不是如果留在韩国会受到的那种限制生活。虽然最近她的父母开始谈论来美国，搬来和她住，这样可以离得近点，但她发现这些对话让她感到紧张。她不想放弃从11岁起就拥有的独立。
I don't feel regret. I don't feel regret that he was there, and that I gave in to this deal. I don't know if I should say I gave in. But I really don't regret the fact that he was there that day, listening to me and saying those things, you know, come with me to a new place, a new world, and all that. I don't think that he was wrong.
我不后悔。我不后悔他在那里，我不后悔我答应了这笔交易。我不知道我是不是该说我妥协了。但我真的不后悔那天他在那里，听我演奏并说出那些话，你知道，带我到一个新的地方、新的世界之类的。我不认为他错了。
Because I have to say, it was just a very adventurous thing to do. And I really feel like if I had a choice to stay home and to do this, I think every time, I would choose it, choose to go.
因为我得说，这确实是一件非常有冒险精神的事。我真的觉得，如果我有机会留在家还是做这个，我觉得每次我都会选它，选去那里。
Jayna's now 23. She's still at Peabody. She gigs with the Lyric Opera Orchestra and Young Concert Artists' Orchestra in Baltimore. She has a sponsor, a businessman in North Carolina who heard her perform and now helps her with a monthly check. At her apartment, after playing three songs for me, Jayna stops and is about to put her violin away. She asks, should I keep playing? And I say, sure, play more. No, she says, I mean the violin. Jayna's still wondering.
杰娜现在23岁。她还在皮博迪。她在巴尔的摩的抒情歌剧管弦乐团和青年音乐家管弦乐团进行演出。她有一位赞助人，一位北卡罗来纳州的商人，他听过她表演，现在每月寄支票帮她。在她的公寓，为我演奏了三首歌后，杰娜停了下来，正准备把小提琴收起来。她问，我还要继续演奏吗？我说，当然，多演奏点。不，她说，我是指小提琴。杰娜还在犹豫。
Act Four, Carmen Becomes Faust.
第四幕，卡门变身浮士德。
When I was nearing my 30th birthday, I decided it was about time to get off welfare. Both the children were in school, and old dreams of being a hippie revolutionary scrounging for a pound of bulgur and soybeans in the mountains didn't seem nearly as romantic as it had five years before. My husband had run off to the Virgin Islands two winters before with a fat Jewish girl who knew somebody down there who had a boat.
当我快要满30岁时，我决定是时候摆脱福利金生活了。两个孩子都在上学，而当嬉皮士革命者在山里搜寻一磅干小麦和大豆的旧梦，看起来远没有五年前那么浪漫。我丈夫在两个冬天前带着一个犹太胖女孩私奔到了维尔京群岛，那女孩在那边有熟人还有条船。
When this story begins, this story of another deal with the devil, another person coming in from the sticks to the big city, Carmen Delzell is living in a tenant farmer's shack, no phone or radio or clock. Water comes from a pump, is heated on an Ashley wood stove. It's 1978. And to earn her way out of there, Carmen Delzell started to go to auctions and thrift stores out in the country, and buy stuff cheap that she could drive into Washington, DC and sell for higher prices at the flea markets there.
在这个故事开始时，这个关于另一个与魔鬼交易的故事，关于另一个人从乡下进大城市的故事，卡门·德尔泽尔住在一个佃农小屋里，没有电话、收音机或钟表。水是从水泵抽出来的，在阿什利木炉上烧热。那是1978年。为了赚点钱摆脱那里，卡门·德尔泽尔开始去乡下的拍卖会和旧货店，买些廉价的东西，然后开车拉到华盛顿特区，在跳蚤市场上卖出更高的价格。
I must have been a sight in those days with my folding tables and clothes racks and raggedy looking children in Georgetown. I think I was pretty then, but I didn't know it. I wore peasant blouses with no brassiere, and my hair was long and curly and white-blond from the sun.
在那段日子里，我带着折叠桌、衣架和衣衫褴褛的孩子们在乔治敦，一定很引人注目。我觉得我当时很美，但我自己不知道。我穿着农民衬衫，不戴胸罩，头发长而卷曲，被太阳晒成了白金色。
You must realize that in those days, hippie women were really different from straight women. We thought we were practically another race. We believed in all kinds of dogmas and rhetoric. We believed it, and we lived it. Not eating meat was one of those. Smoking dope was really important. We believed in karma and revolution and a whole lot of obscure practices which sound silly now but made a whole lot of sense back then.
你必须明白，在那些日子里，嬉皮女性和正统女性真的非常不同。我们认为我们几乎是另一个物种。我们相信各种各样的教条和修辞。我们相信它，并践行它。不吃肉是其中之一。抽大麻真的非常重要。我们相信业力、革命和一大堆现在听起来很傻但在当时却非常有意义的晦涩做法。
So when a young lawyer or real estate broker or something would come along and hang around too long, I didn't know what to think. Didn't they know that we were worlds apart in every way? What could we possibly have to say to each other? I was so naive. When the man who ran the flea market invited me out to dinner at the Steak 'n Egg Kitchen, I was flabbergasted. I was, but I went anyway.
所以当一个年轻的律师或房地产经纪人什么的走过来，还在那儿晃悠太久时，我不知道该想什么。难道他们不知道我们在各个方面都来自不同的世界吗？我们有什么话可说？我真是太天真了。当跳蚤市场的负责人邀请我去Steak 'n Egg Kitchen吃晚饭时，我简直惊呆了。我是，但我还是去了。
By now, it was beginning to get chilly. Money would really be tight when it got too cold to sell on the street, so I decided to go to a fortune teller. She lived and worked in a storefront in Chinatown. She was fat and sneaky-looking and had only one breast. But as it turned out, she was right about everything to come, and she gave me three wishes. I wished for an apartment, a man, and an antique store.
到这时候，天开始变凉了。一旦冷到无法在街上摆摊，钱就会非常紧，所以我决定去找个算命先生。她在唐人街的一个店面里工作。她很胖，看起来很狡猾，只有一只乳房。但事实证明，关于后来发生的一切，她都说对了，她还给了我三个愿望。我许愿要一套公寓、一个男人和一家古董店。
She gave me a strange list of things to buy. They were a bottle of Chinese floor wash, four seven-day candles, red, white, blue, and green, a box of bano sangrados, which means spirit bath, white flowers, jinx remover powder, and Indian money draw soap. I drove back to the country $20 poorer and kind of depressed that I could have been so vulnerable.
她给了我一张奇怪的购物单。那是：一瓶中国地板清洗液，四根七天蜡烛（红、白、蓝、绿），一盒bano sangrados（意为精神沐浴液），白花，去晦粉，和印度“引财”肥皂。我开车回乡下，少了20美元，而且因为自己竟然这么容易受骗而感到有些沮丧。
That was on a Saturday. On Sunday, I poured the bottle of Chinese floor wash into the bucket of fresh pumped water and scrubbed all the floors in the house with it. This was to clear out evil spirits. Then when the children went to sleep, I began the ritual of the spirit bath. I placed the candles around the galvanized tin tub that we used for everything, filled it with kettles of hot water, and poured in the first bottle of red liquid from the box I bought.
那是星期六。星期天，我把那瓶中国地板清洗液倒进刚抽上来的水桶里，用它把房子的所有地板都擦了一遍。这是为了清理邪灵。然后当孩子们睡着后，我开始了精神沐浴的仪式。我把蜡烛摆在那只我们用来做任何事的镀锌铁桶周围，倒满水壶烧的热水，倒入从店里买来的红色瓶子里的第一份液体。
Just before I got in the tub, I arranged the white roses in front of my dead mother's picture. This was to ensure her blessing and ask her to intervene on my behalf. As soon as I got in the water, I got this weird, tingly feeling. The shadows from the candles loomed around me like ghosts, and the water looked like blood.
就在我进木桶前，我把白玫瑰插在死去的母亲的照片前。这是为了确保她的祝福，并请求她代表我进行干预。当我一进水里，就有一种奇怪的刺痛感。蜡烛映出的影子像鬼魂一样在我周围徘徊，水看起来像血一样。
I sat there naked and shivering by the wood stove and prayed out loud for God to send me things I associated with red. I asked for sex, adventure, and central heat. I also asked for red cowboy boots and a ruby ring. On Monday morning, I drove to Culpepper and found the cowboy boots for $2 at the Pink Ladies Shop and the ring in a jar of buttons which they let me have for $0.25. That night, the awful man from the flea market drove out to see me and spent the night.
我赤身裸体、瑟瑟发抖地坐在木炉旁，大声祈祷上帝赐给我与红色相关的东西。我要求性、冒险和中央供暖。我还要求红色牛仔靴和红宝石戒指。星期一早上，我开车去库尔佩珀，在粉红女士商店花2美元买到了牛仔靴，又在一个装满纽扣的罐子里找到了戒指，他们只收了我0.25美元。那天晚上，跳蚤市场的那个讨厌男人开车来看我，并在那儿待了一晚。
I realized my next wishes would have to be more specific. Tuesday evening, I repeated the ritual, except the water turned blue. I found it a harder color to match with things I needed, so I just asked for general good fortune. Nothing special happened Wednesday, but nothing went wrong either.
我意识到接下来的愿望必须更具体。星期二晚上，我重复了仪式，除了水变成了蓝色。我发现这个颜色很难与我需要的东西相匹配，所以我只是求了笼统的“好运”。星期三没什么特别的事情发生，但也什么都没出错。
Well, it went on like that for the next 14 days. My luck began to turn. I found better clothes in the thrift shops than I'd ever found before, and made over $100 at the flea market. My landlord began to smile and wave at me when I drove past his house, and letters with small checks in them arrived at the post office. But I guess I have to get to the unbelievable part, and here's what it is. A handsome young millionaire came up to me the last day of the baths and offered me free rent in a sunny slum apartment, and $10,000 to start my own business. Sounds like a lie, doesn't it? I know it does, but it's true.
嗯，接下来的14天里都是这样。我的运气开始好转。我在旧货店里找到了比以往任何时候都好的衣服，在跳蚤市场上赚了100多美元。我的房东开始在我开车经过他家时冲我微笑和挥手，邮局里也收到了带有小额支票的信件。但我猜我必须说到那不可思议的部分了，事实就是：最后一次洗浴那天，一个英俊的年轻百万富翁走到我面前，主动提出让我免费住进一间阳光充足的贫民公寓，还给我1万美元创业。听起来像谎言，对吧？我知道是，但这是真的。
Soon after we moved there, he fell in love with me, and we all lived together that winter, sleeping on mattresses on the floor and eating Chinese food out of cardboard containers. That was one of the happiest times in my life, though I missed certain things about living alone in the country. The dark side of the magic hadn't revealed itself yet, so we blithely enjoyed our warm rooms, and I thanked Jesus every night for his blessings.
搬过去不久，他爱上了我，那个冬天我们住在一起，睡在地板的床垫上，吃着纸盒装的中餐。那是我一生中最快乐的时光之一，尽管我怀念独自住在乡下的一些东西。魔法的阴暗面还没显现，所以我们无忧无虑地享受着温暖的房间，我每晚都感谢耶稣的祝福。
I've heard that we punish ourselves better and more profoundly than any spirits or gods we can imagine. I hope that's true. I hope that's true because I still feel guilty. Because, you see, David, the millionaire, was married, and I knew it from the very beginning. He invited me to Washington, DC to have dinner with him and his wife.
我听说我们惩罚自己的方式比我们能想象到的任何灵魂或神灵都要更好、更深刻。我希望这是真的。我希望这是真的，因为我仍然感到内疚。因为，你看，大卫，那个百万富翁，是有妇之夫，我从一开始就知道。他邀请我去华盛顿特区和他妻子一起吃晚饭。
I remember everything about that night. I wore an antique dress, platform shoes, and three carved Bakelite bracelets. My entire outfit cost less than $10. His wife had a mink coat, and long, red fingernails. I was very impressed with them both. They'd invited me to drive from my little house in Virginia to discuss a business deal. He was a slum landlord. She had an antique clothing store. They had discovered me selling things at the Georgetown flea market and wanted me to trade clothes for a three-room apartment in a tenement across town. It seemed like a good idea to me at the time.
我记得那晚的一切。我穿了一件古董裙，厚底鞋，戴着三个雕刻的电木手镯。我整套行头不到10美元。他妻子穿着貂皮大衣，留着长长的红指甲。他们俩都让我印象深刻。他们邀请我从我在弗吉尼亚的小屋开车去讨论一笔生意。他是贫民窟房东。她有一家古董服装店。他们在乔治敦跳蚤市场发现了我，想让我用衣服换取城另一边公寓楼里的一套三居室。当时我觉得这是个好主意。
So I took the place. But things didn't really go as they were intended to. The apartment was cramped and lonely. All the other tenants were on strike because the building was falling down. And David, the owner, wanted me to be his mistress. During this time, my visits to the local Haitian voodoo store became more frequent.
所以我接下了那个地方。但事情并没有按预想的那样发展。公寓拥挤且孤独。其他房客都在罢工，因为那栋楼快塌了。而房东大卫想让我当他的情妇。这段时间，我去当地的海地巫毒店的次数变多了。
You must understand that living in the ghetto was very different from living in any other part of town. Even the grocery stores sell statues of Santa Barbara, San Lazaro, and the Virgin Mary. And when one of the neighbors was found dead on the front stoop, the Jamaican woman whose son dressed like a ninja and practiced swinging his nunchucks in the hall put holy candles all around the lobby in the order of the seven African powers.
你必须明白，住在贫民区和住在城里任何其他地方非常不同。甚至连杂货店里都卖圣芭芭拉、圣拉扎罗和圣母玛利亚的雕像。当其中一个邻居被发现死在前廊上时，那个儿子打扮得像忍者、在走廊里练习挥舞双节棍的牙买加女人，在门厅里点了一圈圣烛，摆成了“七大非洲力量”的阵型。
We were the only white family on the block. It was very lonely. My only comfort was sitting in the cool, spooky Catholic church looking at the handmade doll clothes the ladies made for the statues.
我们是那个街区唯一的白人家庭。非常孤独。我唯一的安慰是坐在阴凉、阴森的天主教堂里，看着女士们为雕像亲手缝制的娃娃衣服。
And then, one full moon, I put on my black velvet dress pinned with a rhinestone dagger, wrapped a small box of jinx remover powder in a white handkerchief, and walked across town to the house where David and his wife lived. It was not really clear to me at the time what I was up to. I felt as if I was being guided by an unseen force, but I swear, I had no real idea what I was doing. I took a pine branch and I put it through the mail slot. And then I left this little package on the stoop, said a few magic words, and ran.
然后，在一个满月之夜，我穿上那条别着水钻匕首的黑色天鹅绒裙子，用白手帕包上一小盒去晦粉，穿过城市走到大卫和他妻子住的那栋房子。当时我不太清楚自己在干什么。我觉得自己被一股看不见的力量引导着，但我发誓，我真的不知道自己在做什么。我拿了一根松树枝，把它插进邮箱缝里。然后我把这个小包裹留在门廊上，说了几句咒语，就跑了。
The next morning, when David came out to get the paper, he found the stick and the spell. His wife asked him to go buy half and half for their coffee because they were having weekend guests. David says he doesn't really know why he decided to go to the little tienda by my house, but when he got there, he decided to come see me. Until that moment, neither one of us had felt anything for the other.
第二天早上，当大卫出来拿报纸时，发现了棍子和符咒。他妻子让他去买半牛奶用来冲咖啡，因为他们要有周末客人在家。大卫说他不知道为什么自己决定去我家旁边的那家小店，但当他走到那儿时，他决定来见我。在那一刻之前，我们俩对彼此都没有任何感觉。
When I opened the door, he was standing there crying. He said he loved me and couldn't live without me. I said the same thing, and he never went back home. His wife sued him for $1 million, all the furniture, and the Mercedes. She won, but I got him. It took me years to figure out how to get away.
当我打开门时，他站在那儿哭了。他说他爱我，不能没有我。我也说了同样的话，他就再也没回过家。他妻子起诉他索赔100万美元，以及所有的家具和那辆梅赛德斯。她赢了，但我得到了他。我花了好几年才弄明白怎么逃离。
It's true that I loved him for a while, or at least I thought I did. But looking back on it, I realize I had been alone so long that I would have probably thought I was in love with anybody who took care of me. I remember when he bought me this Diana Ross song, "I Know I'll Never Love This Way Again." I'd play that before he came over and dance around the house and try to get in the mood.
我确实爱过他一段时间，或者至少我是这么认为的。但回想起来，我意识到我孤独的时间太长了，可能任何照顾我的人我都会觉得我爱上了他。我记得当他给我买那首戴安娜·罗斯的歌《我知道我永远不会再这样去爱了》时。在找我之前，我常播放它，在屋子里跳舞，试图让自己进入状态。
Then my brother was found half-dead of a barbiturate overdose in the woods of West Virginia on a commune, and he came to live with us. Four people in a three-room apartment. One thing led to another, and David took us all under his wing. Michael tried to kill himself two more times. Christmas came and went. David gave me $40 a week and took me out to dinner, which sometimes cost three times that.
然后我弟弟被发现因为巴比妥酸盐过量而半死不活地躺在西弗吉尼亚森林里的一个公社里，他搬来和我们一起住。三居室公寓里住了四个人。事情一件接一件，大卫把我们所有人都照顾起来。迈克尔又尝试自杀了两次。圣诞节来了又去了。大卫每周给我40美元，带我出去吃饭，有时候饭钱是那个的三倍。
I felt like I was El Salvador and David was America. I used to scream and cry and beg him to let me go. One of the neighbors put it into words very well when he carved "landlord's whore" on my front door. I refused to let David have it painted over. It was true. There are only two kinds of frenzy that take all my reason away. One is the frenzy of love, one is the frenzy of needing money. It got to the point where I was in a constant frenzy. I needed a lawyer and a psychiatrist.
我觉得自己像萨尔瓦多，大卫像美国。我常尖叫、哭泣并求他放我走。其中一个邻居在我的前门上刻下“房东的婊子”时，很好地用词表达了出来。我拒绝让大卫把那字涂掉。那是真的。只有两种狂乱会让我丧失理智。一种是爱的狂乱，一种是需要钱的狂乱。我陷入了不断的狂乱中。我需要律师和精神科医生。
My cripple brother moved across the street to another hot slum apartment and lived with a black woman named May. They fought over money, other men, his leaving his clothes on the floor for her to pick up, et cetera. She was very beautiful, like Diana Ross, but she stayed drunk on straight gin and watched soap operas all day. David gave him $200 a week to live on. It was part of our understanding even though we never discussed it.
我那个瘸腿弟弟搬到街对面另一间炎热的贫民窟公寓，和一个叫梅的黑人女人住在一起。他们为钱、为别的男人、为他把衣服丢在地板上让她收拾之类的事而吵架。她非常美，像戴安娜·罗斯，但她整天沉溺在纯杜松子酒中，看着肥皂剧。大卫每周给他200美元维持生活。这是我们默契的一部分，尽管我们从未讨论过。
I knew that my staying with him kept my brother from another suicide attempt. The money gave us all a false sense of security, but the thought of it being taken away haunted us constantly. I was 30 years old. The children were eight and four. My brother was 24. And David was 33 and already a millionaire.
我知道我留在他身边阻止了我弟弟另一次自杀企图。这笔钱给了我们所有人虚假的安稳感，但它随时会被拿走的念头一直萦绕着我们。我30岁。孩子们8岁和4岁。我弟弟24岁。大卫33岁，已经是个百万富翁了。
Then one hot night in June, I began to break all the windows in the apartment with my bare hands. I began to scream out the window that this is what happened to a woman when she had to sell her body to pay the rent. David tried to hold me down and cover my mouth, but I broke away and ran down three flights of stairs screaming.
然后在一个炎热的六月晚上，我开始用裸手打破公寓里的所有窗户。我开始对着窗外尖叫，这就是一个女人为了付房租不得不出卖身体的下场。大卫试图按住我、捂住我的嘴，但我挣脱了，跑下三层楼梯，一路尖叫。
When I got out on the cement steps, he and his brother caught me again. But before they realized what was happening, I ripped my dress in two and stood there naked and yelling, "Take it, take it. This is all you want. This is what you pay for, my body, not me, just this body." His brother slapped me in the face and they drug me naked up the cement stairs, scraping the skin off my back.
当我冲到水泥台阶上时，他和他的兄弟又抓住了我。但在他们意识到发生了什么之前，我撕碎了衣服，赤身裸体站在那儿大喊：“拿去，拿去。这就是你们想要的。这就是你们花钱买的，我的身体，不是我，只是这具身体。”他兄弟扇了我一耳光，他们赤身裸体地把我拖上水泥楼梯，背上的皮都被蹭掉了。
I don't remember too much after that, but nothing really changed. We went on living there. My brother went on living across the street. Two years later, he finally did kill himself by jumping out the window. I kept his remains in the kitchen cabinet for a long time.
之后的事我不记得太多了，但一切并没有改变。我们继续住在那儿。我弟弟继续住在那条街对面。两年后，他最终还是跳窗自杀了。我把他的骨灰在厨房柜子里放了很长时间。
But it took me seven years to get rid of David. Ronald Reagan was up for a second term that year, and he was invited to the inaugural ball. David wanted me to go, too. Now, I do know people who would be delighted to go to the inaugural ball just to see what it's like. But I was so superstitious, I was sure God would strike me dead for hobnobbing with the richest and meanest congregation on Earth.
但我花了七年时间才甩掉大卫。那年罗纳德·里根竞选第二个任期，他被邀请参加就职舞会。大卫也想让我去。现在，我确实认识有些人会很高兴去参加就职舞会，看看那是什么样子的。但我太迷信了，我肯定上帝会因为我和地球上最富有、最刻薄的信徒聚在一起而把我打死。
So I went back to the voodoo lady. She told me what to do. First I had to take an apple and cut out its core. Then I was to write my problem on a piece of paper and put it inside. Then I had to wrap the apple with a black ribbon while I chanted, bind him, bind him, take away his power and set me free. And then, on the first night of the new moon, I buried the apple in the nuns' graveyard behind the Sacred Heart Church.
所以我又找了那个巫毒女士。她告诉了我该怎么做。首先我得拿个苹果，挖掉它的核。然后我要把我的问题写在纸条上塞进去。然后我要用黑色丝带缠住苹果，一边念咒，绑定他，绑定他，夺走他的力量，让我自由。然后，在新月的第一个晚上，我把苹果埋在圣心教堂后面的修女墓地里。
The next day, the children and I drove to Cincinnati where an old Hell's Angel friend of mine ran a tattoo parlor. I got him to put a big red heart and dagger up high on my bicep. I knew no good Republican man would ever want to be seen with me again. And you know what? He didn't.
第二天，孩子们和我开车去了辛辛那提，我一个老“地狱天使”朋友在那儿经营一家纹身店。我让他把一颗大红心和匕首纹在我的肱二头肌高处。我知道不会再有任何一个体面的共和党人想再见到我。你知道吗？他真的没再想了。
The truth is that like any other Third World country that tries to cut itself off from America too quickly, our economy has never recovered. And that's why tonight by the full moon, I have returned to the bar where we first made our fateful bargain to beg him for enough money to pay the rent. They say that once you start messing with the occult, you're forever in its debt.
真相是，像任何试图太快切断与美国联系的第三世界国家一样，我们的经济从未复苏。这就是为什么今晚满月时，我又回到了我们最初做出致命交易的那个酒吧，求他给我足够的钱付房租。人们说，一旦你开始接触神秘学，你将永远负债。
Carmen Delzell lives in Buda, Texas. She just opened a vintage clothing store called Lucky Day.
卡门·德尔泽尔住在德克萨斯州的布达。她刚刚开了一家名为“幸运日”的复古服装店。
Act Five, First Contact. You know, there's been so many retellings of the Faust story-- Marlowe, Goethe, Sayers, Thomas Mann, there are various versions of the opera Faust-- but only one person, as far as we can determine, only one person has attempted to tell the story of the devil coming to Earth to steal someone's soul as a children's story. That person is Daniel Pinkwater, and he has agreed to read his book Devil in the Drain, to end our program today.
第五幕，第一次接触。你知道，关于浮士德故事的重述有很多——马洛、歌德、塞耶斯、托马斯·曼，还有各种版本的歌剧《浮士德》——但据我们所知，只有一个人，只有一个人试图以儿童故事的形式讲述恶魔来到地球偷走某人灵魂的故事。那个人就是丹尼尔·平克沃特，他同意朗读他的书《排水沟里的魔鬼》，以此结束我们今天的节目。
I knew that the devil lived inside our plumbing. I could hear him making noises, especially down the drain of the kitchen sink. Sometimes, I would look into the drainpipe with a flashlight and try to see him. Finally, I caught a glimpse of something down there.
我知道恶魔住在我们的管道里。我能听到他发出声音，特别是在厨房水槽的排水沟里。有时候，我会用手电筒往排水管里看，试图看到他。最终，我瞥见了下面有什么东西。
"Hey," I said, "are you the devil?"
“嘿，”我说，“你是恶魔吗？”
"What if I am?" A voice from down the drain answered.
“那又怎样？”排水沟下传来一个声音。
"I just want to know, that's all," I said.
“我只是想知道，仅此而已，”我说。
"I don't have to tell you anything," the voice said.
“我没必要告诉你任何事，”那个声音说。
"Come up here so I can see you," I said.
“上来，让我看看你，”我说。
"Oh no, you'll turn on the water as soon as I get there, and get me all wet."
“哦不，你一见我就会打开水龙头，把我淋得浑身湿透。”
"No I won't. Honestly."
“不，我不会。真的。”
"Well, that's what I would do."
“嗯，换做是我也会这么做。”
"You are the devil, aren't you?"
“你是恶魔，对吧？”
"Yes."
“是的。”
"I'd really like to have a look at you. If I absolutely promise not to turn on the water, will you come up so I can see you?"
“我真的很想看看你。如果我绝对保证不开水，你上来让我看看行吗？”
"Why do you want to see me?"
“为什么你想见我？”
"I just do. Come on up. I won't hurt you. Besides, there are those little bar things across the drain. I couldn't get at you if I wanted to."
“我就是想。上来吧。我不会伤害你的。再说，排水口上有那些细栅栏。就算我想干什么也够不着你。”
"I'm not afraid of you. I'm the devil."
“我不怕你。我是恶魔。”
"Then come up and let me see."
“那就上来让我看看。”
"All right, but if you turn on the water, I'll do some pretty bad things to you."
“好吧，但如果你打开水，我会让你吃不了兜着走。”
"You're really suspicious," I said.
“你真的很疑神疑鬼，”我说。
"You would be too if you were me," the devil said. His voice sounded closer.
“如果我是你，你也会这样，”恶魔说。他的声音听起来更近了。
"Are you coming up?" I asked down the drain.
“你要上来了吗？”我冲排水沟下面问。
"Yes, I'm coming," the devil said. "And don't say it's my fault if you get scared to death."
“是的，我要上来了，”恶魔说。“如果你被吓个半死，别怪我。”
"I'm not scared," I said.
“我不怕，”我说。
"Well, you should be."
“嗯，你应该怕的。”
I could see the devil climbing up the drain. He was pretty small. He wasn't any bigger than the goldfish I had lost down that drain once when I was changing the water in the fishbowl. The devil got up to the little crossed bars. He had a face that reminded me of the fish, and he was almost the same color.
我可以看到恶魔正在顺着排水管爬上来。他挺小的。还没我以前换鱼缸水时掉进下水道的那条金鱼大。恶魔爬到了小十字栅栏那儿。他有一张让我想起那条鱼的脸，颜色也几乎一模一样。
"Well, here I am," the devil said. "You're terrified, right?"
“好了，我到了，”恶魔说。“你吓坏了吧，对吧？”
"Do you remember when I lost my fish down this drain?" I asked.
“你还记得我那条鱼掉进这个下水道了吗？”我问。
"Sure I do," the devil said. "You murdered him."
“当然记得，”恶魔说。“你谋杀了它。”
"I did not. It was an accident."
“我没有。那是场意外。”
"Sure it was," the devil said. "Poor fish, he probably trusted you."
“当然是，”恶魔说。“可怜的鱼，它可能还信任你呢。”
"The water overflowed, and he got sloshed out of the bowl and down the drain," I said. "I don't think he was smart enough to trust me or not trust me. Fish are dumb."
“水溢出来了，它被冲出了鱼缸，掉进了下水道，”我说。“我不觉得它聪明到会信任我或不信任我。鱼是很笨的。”
"That's right," the devil said. "Tell yourself that. I heard him crying for help. You didn't even care."
“说得好，”恶魔说。“你就这么对自己说吧。我听见它在求救。你根本不在乎。”
"I did care," I said. "But I didn't kill him on purpose."
“我在乎，”我说。“但我不是故意杀它的。”
"But you admit you killed him."
“但你承认是你杀了它。”
"Is that what you do?" I asked.
“这就是你做的事吗？”我问。
"What?"
“什么？”
"Try to make people feel bad about things they can't help?"
“试图让别人对自己无法控制的事情感到内疚？”
"It's one of the things I do," the devil said. "Now admit it, you feel pretty horrible about killing that fish, right?"
“这是我做的事情之一，”恶魔说。“现在承认吧，你对自己害死那条鱼感到很糟糕，对吧？”
"I didn't kill him," I said, "and to tell the truth, I don't feel that bad about it. I'm sorry it happened, but it wasn't my fault."
“我没杀它，”我说，“而且说实话，我没觉得有多糟糕。很遗憾发生这种事，但不是我的错。”
"I'm getting bored talking about your stupid fish," the devil said. "How come you haven't mentioned how frightening I am, and at the same time, sort of fascinating?"
“谈论你那条笨鱼真让人无聊，”恶魔说。“你怎么没提我有多吓人，同时又有点迷人？”
"You look a little like a fish," I said. "How come you live in the plumbing?"
“你看起来有点像条鱼，”我说。“你怎么会住在管道里？”
"Again with the fish," the devil said. "I live in the plumbing because I can do whatever I please."
“又是鱼，”恶魔说。“我住在管道里是因为我想干嘛就干嘛。”
"How come you're so small?"
“你怎么这么小？”
"I'm as big as I need to be," the devil said. "Now how about you getting me a pretzel? Do you have any of those skinny salty ones?"
“我需要多大就能有多大，”恶魔说。“给我拿个椒盐卷饼怎么样？你有那种细细咸咸的吗？”
I got the devil a pretzel. I pushed it down the drain. He ate it.
我给恶魔拿了个椒盐卷饼。我把它塞进下水道。他吃了。
"That was lousy," he said. "I know you only got it for me because you're so frightened of me."
“太难吃了，”他说。“我知道你给我只是因为你怕我。”
"Look," I said, "I got you the pretzel because you asked for it. You want another pretzel, I'll get you another pretzel. I happen to be a good-natured kid, and I'm not in the least afraid of you."
“听着，”我说，“我给你椒盐卷饼是因为你要。你还想要，我再给你拿一个。我正好是个好脾气的孩子，一点也不怕你。”
"Yes I do," the devil said.
“我还想要，”恶魔说。
"Do what?"
“干什么？”
"Yes, I do want another pretzel."
“没错，我还要一个椒盐卷饼。”
"I'll get it."
“我去拿。”
"Ha, the kid's terrified," the devil said to himself. I heard him say it.
“哈，这孩子吓坏了，”恶魔自言自语道。我听到了。
"That does it," I said. I turned on both taps, hot and cold.
“够了，”我说。我打开了冷热水龙头。
"Hey, no fair," the devil shouted.
“嘿，不公平，”恶魔大喊。
"Too bad," I said.
“真遗憾，”我说。
I heard the devil shouting and gurgling a long way down the drain pipe. He was really mad.
我听见恶魔在排水管深处尖叫和打水花。他气疯了。
"That was a rotten trick," he shouted. "You ought to be ashamed."
“那是卑鄙的诡计，”他大叫。“你应该感到羞耻。”
"I'm not," I said.
“我没有，”我说。
Daniel Pinkwater's book, Devil in the Drain, has been banned by children's libraries all over America. Really.
丹尼尔·平克沃特的书《排水沟里的魔鬼》已被全美各地的儿童图书馆禁阅。真的。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, Peter Clowney, and myself. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hit, and Margy Rochlin.
嗯，我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克、阿丽克斯·斯皮格尔、彼得·克劳尼和我制作。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like a copy of our program, call us at 312-832-3380 here in Chicago at WBEZ. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果你想要一份节目副本，请致电我们在芝加哥WBEZ的电话312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱是[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给你更多《美国生活》的故事。